what's up party people you are watching
honest trailer commentaries for the
black panther check out our actual
honest trailer then come back here and
see what we had to say about it what we
left out of what you saw yeah ed about
something up right yeah the show there
you go
so here we are the white wolf to my
right is Joestar white wolf to my left
is Dan Merle and I have spent today
Gilbert another white wolf here we are
talking about one of my favorite
superhero movies of the past however
many years yeah it's a good film it film
goodies they're always hard to do all
rights do the good ones not easy
phantom not easy to do yeah yeah I think
that I'm a big fan more so than black
panther of mr. Wran koogler
because after Creed and then this one
and then Fruitvale before this like holy
yeah that guy I make a movie and
he's younger than all of us and what
have we done with her life I know right
like his previous team took care of like
a bit yeah saw that as a storyboard yeah
okay yeah
Ryan Cougars super talented this movie
felt like it belong to the Marvel
Universe but also its own setting and I
don't look going on and what else is
there the first superhero movies where
we got to the third act and I was like I
really wish these two would stop
fighting and start talking like yeah
just like I don't want to see them fight
I want to see chadwick boseman or
Michael B Jordan sitting across the
table from each other
doing this as a verbal duel like they
were just so great in their parts and I
love the conflict between them so much
that like I didn't care about flipping
around on the train tracks with the
vibranium train and the magnet so I was
just like just look these these
guys really go ahead I think that's a
testament to characters you care about
like before the show just went off the
rails every episode of Dexter I was like
I hope he stops killing people and
everyone gets on the same page
I cared about everybody on either end
was just like just have figured out
please I like all of you and I was the
same once everyone started swinging in
the third act yeah I think you would
rather just have them all sit down and
hash it out right I do think that
speaking of the third act which is we
got a nitpick so let's start there
that's where people really turned on
Black Panther like boom yeah like is it
like um is it Dan Kahlua yeah him right
like he he was like the river tribe he's
like you didn't bring back claw well I'm
gonna murder my countrymen now thank you
you've had a weekend to do your job yeah
this guy's stronger okay I don't know
the the big like CGI I know there were
actors too but like mostly CGI armies
clashing in the field I give it a pass
for the concept of armored rhino
charging into battle in a Marvel movie
the the idea of that was made me happy
enough that the execution was I was kind
of like you know what is fine as a riot
it's an armored rhino yeah I think is
especially because of the first two acts
leading up to that how how much just you
know in terms of sorry all my migraine
medicine just kicked in in a and I lost
words just how much social context is
put in and the the argument about
isolationism versus a versus
globalization and everything is so good
for a Marvel movie that you're almost
you're almost taken aback that I think
that when it goes into third act Marvel
movie mode you're kind of like oh and
it's almost even a little more jarring
yeah that's why that turn works I think
is because Michael B Jordan both this
performance in the way his characters
written you are so even though like
objectively he's like I want to go kill
a bunch of people the way that they get
him there and the way that he presents
this case you're like I like it it was a
little bit like send send country's guns
question marks prophet alright you have
some spies and you're gonna send them
guns but like you know well you know his
hearts in the right place what he wants
to do you know the best laid plans uh
you know don't always get there yeah I
think the real villain that really snuck
under the radar is our other Hobbit
friend is uh the CIA guy who's like yeah
we trained him he's one of ours we
taught him how to do all of this we
dermis all the time but I'll help you
with the drone I hope you wouldn't fly
the drone yeah whoopsy
oops which is is honestly kind of a cool
touch cuz I mean that's very that's very
United States where they're like hey
this was our bad and even though it was
like oh wait it was well they don't
really acknowledge it they're like yeah
but you're still with us go get in the
ark to go get in the arcade plane yeah
yeah so again well done Kugler and
everyone involved but let's see very
difficult Creed makes me cry every time
I watch it take that
after 17 movies the MCU
finally went black putting out a black
crew black ass superhero movie that's
one of the best ever released leaving
its haters with only one option watching
every other MCU movie ever made
that's kind of the things like you have
to acknowledge the monumental
significance of the fact that it had
unprecedented success for a movie
directed by an african-american starring
I mean you know again when we're looking
at how do you get into this like that's
something that you can't really there's
no joke to be add there so you just have
to acknowledge it and just like what's
the joke to be made about if you can't
make a joke about the situation which is
not really a joke there it's like turn
it around and like what's the humor on
the other side of it yeah which is the
fact that like people if you really want
to complain about this movie like are
literally all of the other because well
yeah that's the same as like why is
there no white pit there was there no
white History Month because that's just
everything else that is that's the MCU
let's keep going again still the top you
thought black panther called it every
black icon
he's suiting up as black panther a
superhero with a high-tech suit of iron
man the all-natural steroids of Captain
America and the invisible jet of Wonder
Woman but one thing can't even say him
from all the other MCU heroes not cuz
he's black not cuz he's royalty nope
it's cuz this Marvel hero just won't
quit
are you finished
okay Dom literally fought holder of an
infinity stone was a dance-off and yeah
and his as his father was dying they
were like making Baywatch jokes exactly
like there's a gym but again it's almost
jarring it but but but it works I mean
to those who think like oh so now you're
complaining about there not being equips
you just complete about it's like
everything that we do in an honest
trailer isn't a complaint observation
and that's like that's actually one of
the things that makes him a good
character is you do have 17 other people
then like he and mostly Doctor Strange
but even Doctor Strange is Arkin yeah I
guess some snarky yeah I can't think of
anyone less apt to make a joke in them
see you guys well cap makes jokes cuz
he's lame but yeah he's kind of the butt
of jokes but of jokes are the he's he's
awkward but you know how it's just very
stoic badass even Drax with no sense of
humor makes way more jokes yeah yeah
like who doesn't understand idioms or
whatever yeah alright do you need that
balance there even groots joking around
yeah that's true if you read the script
that's part of what made Sheree such a
great character in this movie though is
that she's the funny one and he's the
it's it's getting how Comedy Works and
realizing you don't always have to do
the same formula you can make other
people funny and what makes it funnier
is that the other person doesn't think
it's funny and it's not just a non-stop
quit the fun yeah quit off we have
enough of that Peter quit let's go
journey to Wakanda a combination of the
Jetsons and a 1990s Jet magazine it's
the source of all the world's vibranium
a material so powerful it tops Tony
Stark's tech and dr. Strange's magic as
the BS they can do whatever the script
needs it to do any money
literally how does a metal bus how does
it metal do everything if it's a metal
it does every properties but it also
powers things it's also unlike Ram they
throughout them it's undetectable by
metal detectors somehow movie he's like
yeah cuz like the weapons
oh yeah undetectable by metal detectors
they could do anything but it's the
strongest well I do wish they had um
change this one up a little bit and like
maybe an alien ship crashed there that
it's a meteor yeah I know but like I
wish they'd explained away some of this
with like there was more alien stuff
crash that maybe had some easier
instruction something yeah come on
vibranium pick to chip away at the
meteor because otherwise how would the
material people get any of the vibranium
off the CG oh this is what happens when
you ask for this kind of stuff yeah you
can in discussions about vibranium picks
borrow a cap shield to just yeah it is
ding ding at it of course that then
raises a question of like of all the
things you get the rarest material on
earth and they like shield shield you'll
make a disk out of it
really yeah well go with the disk yeah
they were stupid Americans in the 1940s
I it's not shocking that they were like
what do you do with this metal and
stretch it wait with with the themes of
like colonialism in this movie and
people stealing vibranium that means
that cap shield was stolen from Wakanda
and should be returned it doesn't belong
in a museum
yeah makanda get this man a very
different shield not the one he took
from us that once day like like what
Wolverine nubs are ever in infinite
world yeah yeah do not like those huh
not a shield yeah he he dropped it at
the end of civil war he's like yeah but
no one picked it up I don't I don't
remember anyone picking it up maybe it's
still sitting in that yeah ended Winter
Soldier factory I'm sure we'll find out
eventually or it's just in its in Tony's
scrapbook along with the breakup now
that Steve wrote oh yeah it was
especially annoying because they're like
get this man a shield and there is with
like you can shield swim fins on his
eyes it's a great trailer lines that's a
great trick someone get this you do it
they just didn't find it yeah they just
cut the scene where the guy's like hey
Steve I know
T'Challa told me to get this is what I
found yeah yeah I have these yeah aliens
are laying and I'll have a lot of time
to get through inventory yeah that's the
only yeah infinity war Steve Rogers just
running around in one of those rhinos
two rhinos yep Rhino skates alright
let's get going he has been hidden for
centuries thanks to an ironclad policy
of asking people not to say anything but
after sitting out the slave trade brutal
dictators two world wars multiple alien
invasions and a sentient AI using stolen
vibranium to destroy the earth it seems
like they're finally ready to get
involved in Bay Area real estate I
bought this building that's a great
kitten steps you guys yeah pause I mean
we might get taken attest to this set
but I think that the movie itself is
making the case the whole time that
Wakanda needs to come out of it's shell
literally yes
and the world's been the entire world
Wakanda included has been threatened in
the MCU multiple times and they seem to
have one up on everybody else in that
regard and it's kind of shown in their
valley with their alien tech yeah
eyes everywhere they knew about Ultron
they knew about all this stuff and we
saw the there is the end credit where he
talks to the UN and the UN's like what
do you have to offer us and he winks at
the camera yeah it's a funny observation
that after the whole arc of the movie
he's like I bought this building right
yeah I've heard those of us obviously
get the point that he was using the
buildings we know we know its hue more
human its exaggerating the fact that we
are reducing his very well stated
intentions and goals to buying real
estate in the Bay Area because that is a
humorous way of looking
the city I was just thinking back to
it's hard sometimes I my mind was going
somewhere else an unrelated point of all
the people in Wakanda that aren't like
in the city are they holding crisis
sectors like are they just pretending to
be farmers all day no I'd like to just
know they have farmers and farmers yeah
I think they just like I mean they can
go in and out freely I think it's it's
like the farmers to drive into town that
we have here in the United States they
still have that right farmers to drive
into town yes just the tenant that's
what the farmers of the town is just
really really cool yeah that of uh yeah
town okay so they're not just like all
right it's your turn to go and pretend
you're dirt-poor like oh hit the road
with a stick to make sure like the UN
doesn't catch on I bet they got like
yeah I'm sure it's just like everyone
needs farmers and you got a gross stuff
and they're you know they're still on
their own I don't think they can eat the
vibranium so they have to go well well I
don't know I think it seeped actually
that's the things that see the the flour
seriously yeah yeah that's what I've
implied is that they're eating the
vibranium has leached into the soil and
the magic herb is but not everyone gets
to eat the magic herb yeah a special
diet yeah that's reserved oh yeah
although this does now hit the wall
where after infinity war where Tony
Stark's just like adds nanotech and his
suit just magically appears it's like
what does what kind of have to offer
cuz all their stuff now just looks well
that was the boy forget they were making
in this movie was that that the world
was catching up and so kill mongering
Harris and his crew were saying we have
to make our move now because soon
they're perfect we're not gonna have the
the the technological advantage
yeah and Tony Stark is such a broken man
or so cool inside he's just like oh I
guess magic exists in the last movie and
was like pretty on board pretty quick
for some of the undercuts that's the
band of science like dr. strange is
whole it took him a whole movie to get
over that and Tony Stark's like we're
with the Wizards like we're trying to
get the necklace with the Wizards that's
good but he seen some stuff yeah he also
flew a nuclear bomb into a portal into
outer space and fell back through the
portal still science
yeah I think he's I was with him on that
lid I think he just at this point it
doesn't matter he's going with wave your
hands cool yeah alright keep eyes
after taking 18 movies to get six
quality villains that's just three
movies to cut it back to two maybe one
but for one shining moment we had call
Andy circuses Joy's betrayal of a guy
who doesn't have seizures that suit my
auntie he's the buffest dude to ever
graduate from MIT who's ribbed for your
pleasure and who actually wins the moral
argument and changes the hero's mind
where was Wakanda to turn your backs on
the rest of the world so wait kill
mugger was right I am not used to this
much nuance in my Marvel villains quick
make him choking old lady so I know who
to root for yeah I feel like they had to
take his like correct ideology and but
then just make him like just so
over-the-top violent and imperialist
that like you know oh yeah it's like in
a rom-com where she ends up with the new
guy and he seems fine and then in the
third act and they're like oh she's
supposed to be in love with the main
character they make that guy psychotic
or you know something crazy so you're
like oh he's it what did that mean had
it together but now he's awful yeah and
that was my favorite part of the movie
though it was the fact that you had of
quote-unquote villain who had a truly
grievance that was a hundred percent in
the right his father was was murdered
yeah and he was left to fend for himself
and there was a country that's sat by
and allowed any number of in justices to
happen over decades centuries perhaps
and that you know he only hindered by
the fact that he went too far
ideologically in the sense of like you
know if what kinda is gonna get involved
they also can't allow him to do what he
wants to do but the fact that like he
was he was 90 percent a hundred percent
right which I love like I I'm so tired
of particularly I think Marvel has a
villain issues of like not so much in
the last few but
as they were finding their way of just
like I'm gonna beat you up Erica I love
power yeah I love that complexity of
just like a villa it's not really I
wouldn't even call him a villain he's
he's an antagonist I guess but only in
the sense that he is directly
antagonizing the protagonist protagonist
yeah no I love the the complexity that
they gave him and the yeah and I think
that wouldn't it wouldn't have taken
away from it and would have had it even
more complexity if he hadn't choked the
priestess and shot his girlfriend for no
real reason
yeah well yeah and at the same time I
got ad that come it is a comic comic
book miss yeah but also I what you said
is exactly right the clock could have
been such a cool runner villain like
turkeys for defenders Turks my favorite
character in defenders every time he
pops up I get very excited
mhm and any circus was so fun in this
movie yeah he's a great like d-lister
yeah he'll I became the main villain and
yeah b-but because a bridesmaid yeah and
that that's the perfect spot and shot
off screen but definitely like he was
slumped over and there was a bullet
noise and I hope they don't do it we're
like they shot just to the left of them
to morning or something but he deserves
a hand for the performance even you know
kill monger go that's such a waste
like imagine putting kill monger in in
jail with some villains that are just
guys that are like I love power and then
kill monger gets in their head with his
like actual complexity and ideas and
makes them scarier yeah but you know the
Black Panther
T'Challa died and went over that
waterfall you know it's comic-book movie
they can all come back this is true this
is true there was one thing that didn't
make the trailer that I wrote in my
notes which is that like when they're
giving that the the briefing on kill
monger Bilbo Watson will call him yeah
Martin Freeman was saying like he's got
hundreds of confirmed kills and it's
like ah but he didn't confirm the one
the one the one girl he should confer
just toss them over toss them over the
waterfall that was his villain hubris he
didn't know he was in a company but he
didn't know the other baby that would
have been enough but yeah who's the guy
in the ice mountain's Baku Baku yeah I
didn't count on him Baku burying him in
an inch of snow which I guess is
vibranium is magic that's double magic
cocktails all the time stabbed and
thrown off a cliff just put them in the
snow I can't tell you how many times my
ass has been saved by being put in some
stuff it's yeah that's just science yeah
grandma's old cough medicine well there
he is
while the boys are at play it's the
women of Black Panther who do all the
work like a co a literal snatcher of
wigs Sheree expert in weaponized beans
Angela Bassett as herself and Nakia who
after all the debate between T'Challa
and kill monger was making the same case
all along and never got the credit for
it
bah Conda is strong enough to help
others and protect ourselves at the same
time also she saved the royal family Oh
also she say the future of the black
panther Wow
I'm not used to this much agency my
marvel of interest quick Harrogate
rescued so I know who the heroes are so
enjoy this movie and renting must write
this rocks a great story great things
and great cultural does she wasn't an
offence lets you forget an
underdeveloped love story on a mission
you see I or the big forgettable third
act opposite the bitter punch yeah
in other words it's a Marvel movie the
movie but I'm sure some people will
again we're not it's it's it exceeds the
limitations of its genre I think yeah
we're not trashing them event like
people say like oh so you're gonna
ignore all the good stuff and just point
out the bad stuff like no we've just
pointed out all the good stuff but it
has the hallmarks of by and large Marvel
movies are really good with really a
third X and soso CGI stories and it's
very undeveloped area developed flow
stories doesn't mean a bad movie you put
those two things on the scale the good
outweighs the bad but that's the formula
yep I would love the version of black
panther that was just an ideological
debate between an even more nuanced
ideological debate between kill monger
and my dinner with kill monger yes I
would love that
however that's just that we don't live
in a reality where that movie is going
to get made hopefully down the road but
right now yeah they're on a train track
right there are there are more movies
that have done it I'm trying to think of
them I think like the finale for civil
war and other ones were just the the
final battle of the climactic battle is
more character motivated in like the
yeah the character arcs haven't been
resolved and then they start fighting
but like it's being resolved through the
action yeah and at the end of it it's
resulted an advantage to the Civil War
had to which I was really hoping black
panther would do was Evans and Robert
Downey jr. were allowed to act ya know
the max the the mask was off the Captain
America cowl was off and they actually
like you said the conflict is being
reserved resolved through this action
and that that was my one I think
disappoint with black panther was I was
like Michael B Jordan can do action on
camera we know this and so can chadwick
boseman and so it was really kind of
hoping for just those two guys getting
back in the waterfall yeah yeah get him
back in the waterfall and so to speak
and there's enough personal stuff there
that that could have been a really
compelling gripping thing instead of CGI
train flipped fight
but everything that wasn't that all the
interplay between them when they're not
doing that when their wait while their
suits are morphing whatever it's great
yeah yeah that's a big it's just like
we're not knocking the movie in the
sense of saying that like everything
isn't validated because it has these
things we're saying like this is a great
movie that has these despite this it has
these things yeah and and again it at
some point Disney has to go in and be
like we really need to sell some armored
rhino toys so let's really get them in
there and Lego needs a black panther
versus kill mugger train playset yeah
the iPhone game we need to unit the AR
thing where we're using the drones to
shoot down the other drones yeah exactly
the Air Force but product placement on
this but I mean just that the last
moments where they sit and like watch
the Sun Rise or set I can't remember
what time of day the fight was anymore
set yeah I was the sunset was was
fantastic and while I wish the villain
had lived that was a great way to go out
it made sense for him to just be like so
you can arrest me no that's that's
stupid yeah alright let's wrap it up
story the superhero formerly known as
Prince a prince oh there's Wallis Lupita
you're so fine you're so fine you blow
my mind Lupita Lupita fever the shaky
head Bilbo Watson token token white guys
joke we added a lot of calculus on this
one dan I think probably rightly so was
like if we don't say the same Tolkien
white guys thing that every single other
funny - semi funny person that's it
everybody else is gonna comment you
could call them the token white guys
here's what happened
and it goes back to a previous Martin
Freeman project that we worked on which
was we did the I think it was a civil
war trailer and we talked about cap and
Bucky and how they have a crush on each
other
haha you know whatever the internet name
haha and we got so many moves it's like
I'm so sick of every time so we're talks
what captain Bucky talked about - being
gay like well is if we have to be gay
okay that's fair that's fair because
there so then this is my fault
the sherlock trailer which i think was
right after that was like the next one
and I wrongly as we were doing the fight
as I was doing the final like a look at
the trailer said let's take out the John
Locke Watson Sherlock gay joke because
we just did that last week in Civil War
and I it's it's a little played yeah you
want to find something new to say about
it and that was a huge mistake and the
entire conversation around that trailer
became like how could you not mention
the third love with each other so I
learned a lesson there which is like if
just because the joke is obvious doesn't
mean you shouldn't make it we just need
to figure out how to make that joke with
your non obvious way yeah we figured out
how to play it I think token token white
guys joke is the perfect way to throw it
in there the token white guys thing we
didn't come up with it we can't just say
it Sam repeated joke that was an IMDB
trivia yeah all right we had to make a
reference to it so there's Joe take her
home the best Disney Princess
wardog way of the samurai got out the
Arsenio Hall Show
you know his hearts in the right place
but maybe don't let every drawers keep
any guys with one arm in custody guys
over two so weird streak to be working
on but there it is yeah two guys with
one arm
zero captured anything we didn't put in
let's see what Conda is strong enough to
help others and protect ourselves at the
same time yeah I think she can do better
than a little cat Prince she should get
herself a big dog
Oh story black cat patro grumpy cat
nermal Simba I'm just naming canister
pissed off he's Prince Erik whack
Panther Cat Stevens she's your queen to
be Jane bond
Michonne impossible Johnny English agent
coulson 2.0 black widow baby genius cue
barcoo let the dogs know quite know
where to put the Ruff Ryders yeah
Undercover Brother
you know since he's the Chuck his
brother and he's like undercover what
actually watch the throne has you got a
mixtape coming out oh yeah yeah actually
there is one the adult send you the
soundcloud link if you lock I would
totally buy that couldn't get it on this
booking a jolt Ron South Korea is
probably helping no more superheroes
visit their country yes all on the roads
to highways and byways are under
infrastructure doesn't see constant
attack from vibranium Laden a superhero
cattle in Korea to defend the roads I
was gonna say well they well they get a
Korean superhero sort of in to counter
bounces
probably not but but that'd be a good
villain like from my point of view the
Avengers are yeah actually that needs to
happen yeah awesome and then they
eventually get on the same page and
punch an alien perfect help me keV I
think the important thing we learned
from this is that normal is a male cat
the guys that nerville was the girl
double-checking is Jim Davis drew nermal
with big lashes but that's only to
indicate nirmal's relative youth voiced
by a lady also voiced by a lady not
normal and then I looked it up to double
check the spelling cuz I was gonna call
Sheree Nirmal found out normal voice a
boy yeah as you can tell we at some
point we're so desperate for starring
that we just started looking at cats
cats and just putting them on random
character oh there's a bunch we didn't
even record I think I called the the
honor guard SWAT Kats Panther Oh norm I
do like mr. Mistoffelees and yeah it's
these kind of insights that you watch
this show down to the bitter end for
I've got to save something for Black
Panther - oh yeah yeah
guys anything else any more cat puns any
final thoughts I thought this one was
pretty perfect it's a good it's a good
movie that we're having a little bit of
fun with and I hope people will yeah
have fun with it with us cuz should we
have called her declawed we should have
called him declawed we called claw
declawed did we yeah thanks but I
thought this movie was the cat's meow
and or pajamas what do you think did you
like the movie do you like this video
did you like that other video where
we're talking about in this video I
don't care but you can come in bed in
the comments below next week we'll be
back with kind of like a 3 for 1 special
right now yeah three for one yeah oh
that one we'll see if it turns out that
way you as see on TV yeah yeah seen on
TV
so Christmas might be coming early guys
and you'll know what we're talking about
next week here on honest trailer
commentaries bye
you
[Music]